i'm just trying to fix my pillow
placement i don't know where the hell to
put them all right
whatever so i recently took off my case
and everything on my iphone it seems to
be the trend now everybody's going
caseless i am unable to do this because
this phone is so
slippery like it just slips out of my
hand
like butter ow i was texting the other
night in bed and i'm like this i'm like
this is me this is me just
lounging
taking my nap and i dropped it right on
my face and let me just tell you didn't
feel good it didn't feel good at all i
don't know how people do it like this is
look at this
like it is
it's just like
look at me look at me i'm a phone like
this should not be like this this is
nothing
this is not good
the only saving grace is the apple logo
it's like oh okay even with a case on it
i'm walking down the street and the
phone jumps out of my hand this thing
has a life of its own and i don't
understand how it happens it's like
libby i'm a lobster and i'm unable to
clasp on
things it's fortunately not actually
shattered i mean i've had cases on it i
just don't want the back to get
scratched but then you don't actually
get to really enjoy the beauty of it
if it's in a case god you look really
good like if you were walking down the
street and i saw you i'm not a very
forward person i won't normally engage
and be like yo you look great but i
would come up to you and say yo you'll
look great i would do it i'd be like hey
shawty anyway i don't even know why i
made this video i had just been thinking
about discussing how this is not like
it's great it's it's nice i love it and
i don't know if i'm like the only one
like do you guys have cases on your
phone like what are you doing what
should i do
what am i doing
what is happening
who are you
who am i
where do i come from
where did you go
i don't know um i love you guys i just
wanted to sit and chat for a hot minute
about how slippy the iphone it says
snippy it goes slippy i hold it and it's
like where you going gone it just hit me
in the ankle
you hurt me
all right bye